para analizar esta medida conectamos con
Ana Cristina González ella es pionera
del movimiento causa justa una de las
organizaciones que busca eliminar el
delito de aborto del Código Penal
bienvenido France 24 inicio
preguntándole por la posición del jefe
de estado que incluso señaló
textualmente que esta situación no se
puede convertir en que el aborto en
Colombia se vuelva un mecanismo
anticonceptivo Cómo toman ustedes esas
afirmaciones
Hola Muchas gracias por este espacio y
por las preguntas pues lo primero decir
que es muy triste tener un presidente de
la república
la cosa juzgada que corresponde a la
corte constitucional y que como queda
claro este estudio de la demanda que
nosotros presentamos causa justo es un
movimiento que está integrado por más de
100 organizaciones que recorren más de
20 ciudades del país y a la que se han
sumado aliados de la política del mundo
cultural como explicamos en el
movimiento ha habido muchos cambios
desde el año 2006 hasta la fecha y era
un momento
con argumentos en derecho de realizar
ese estado de las cosas bueno ustedes en
causa justa pues lo que buscan es
eliminar el delito del aborto del Código
Penal Entonces qué significa que se
aprueba esta interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo pero no se haya eliminado este
delito
Bueno lo primero es decir que logramos
un primer paso gigantesco logramos que
en Colombia no vaya delito durante las
primeras 24 semanas del embarazo
hasta la semana 24 y tampoco cuando lo
hace después de la semana 24 de las tres
causales
entonces El Avance y el logro que
tuvimos fue gigantesco histórico y nos
pone la vanguardia no solo América
a la interpretación de Los profesionales
de saludo de los operadores judiciales y
para eso y este es el segundo gran
desafío vamos a trabajar de la mano de
un nuevo congreso que esperamos venga
renovable unas nuevas autoridades que
tengan prácticas más democráticas
sin el delito aborto es decir fuera del
Código Penal porque tú tienes políticas
y posibilidades digamos de acciones muy
distintas y muy diversas para proteger
la vida de las mujeres y también para
proteger pues la vida información en
todos los embarazos deseados en Colombia
que lamentablemente no son ni siquiera
la mitad